Justice League it's finally here and
it's a who's who what's what and where
the hell are we of the DC Universe there
wouldn't be time in 12 videos to find
out all the hidden surprises on this
movie but let's try to tackle the big
stuff now I know it's almost Christmas
but let's talk during the film's first
major action sequence showing Batman
hunting down a para demon and Gotham
mirrors the opening of the first new 52
Justice League comic origin granted the
Caped Crusader got a hand from Green
Lantern in the comics but yeah bat
flicks got this also did you catch the
neon Jannah sign in the background of
that scene this is probably a reference
to Janus cosmetics the makeup company
owned by Roman sionis who becomes the
Batman villain black mask now a black
mask is rumored to appear in the
upcoming Suicide Squad follow up Gotham
City sirens it's like you know
foreshadowing and there are plenty more
comic book callbacks to come watch huh
Batman laments that humanity tends to
act like the Doomsday Clock has a snooze
button this reference is both the
upcoming DC Comics event Doomsday Clock
and a crucial plot point from The
Watchmen which was also adapted into a
movie by Zack Snyder and hey did you see
Billy Crudup joining the DCE you as the
Flash's dad Henry Allen of course you
did he played dr. Manhattan in The
Watchmen which was also directed by Zack
Snyder Wonder Woman drops a reference to
a long ago war between Amazonians and
Atlanteans now call me crazy but that
could definitely be referencing the
iconic flash point crossover arc set in
an alternate timeline where the Justice
League doesn't exist and the Amazons are
at war with Atlantis or it just sounds
cool you know one of those speaking of
war let's talk battle scenes especially
that epic one related in flashback by
Hippolyta where all of Earth's Mightiest
Heroes unite to push back Steppenwolf's
forces of course you probably noticed a
Green Lantern in the mix uh where were
they when Batman needed them but did you
see
that Diana's father Zeus was there as
well also David Thewlis reprises his
Wonder Woman role as Aries in a brief
cameo now we're not at the end but let's
talk about the end credits real quick I
really really hope everyone stayed for
the credits or you miss not one but two
of the best scenes what you left early
also how can I even hear what you're
saying right now this is crazy and Mehta
the mid-credits scene finds Superman and
the flash having a little race to the
coastline to see who's actually the
fastest this has happened a few times in
DC Comics and the flash usually wins hey
someone has to beat Superman at
something sometimes or it's no fun the
final scene brings back Jesse
Eisenberg's Lex Luthor and introduces
Joe Manganiello as the iconic DC villain
Deathstroke aka
Slade Wilson Luthor mentions forming a
league of our own this not only
references that terrific 1993 comedy
about the women's baseball league but
also the eventual formation of the
Legion of Doom a collective of DC's most
vile supervillains look for them in
Justice League 2 or possibly cyborg 1 or
the all new adventures of poison ivy or
whatever Warner Brothers comes up with
next let's get into some of the moments
that you might have missed did you
notice this quick shot panning the front
page of the Metropolis Post newspaper
lookout Daily Planet you got competition
it mentions three likely aliens who
returned to their respective home worlds
last year Supes
David Bowie and Prince are IP in peace
our IP in peace Alfred's little crack
about fighting wind up exploding
penguins also stands out fun this is the
days where mom's biggest concerns were
exploding windup penguin
DC has no immediate plans to update one
notably bird-like member of Batman's
rogues gallery Danny DeVito your legacy
is safe for now though we'd like to see
the trash man join the DC you also did
you catch both Danny Elfman's original
Batman theme and John Williams original
Superman theme in the Justice League
score they're in there though used
sparingly Elfman actually composed the
full Justice League score trivia time
let's end with some fun facts the movie
keeps a lot of the backstory and details
surrounding arch-nemesis Steppenwolf
mysterious but the comics supply a lot
of additional insight when your teacher
used to talk about the magic of reading
yeah
this is what they meant a lot of the
elements around Steppenwolf story
including the mother boxes and the
parademons are based on Jack Kirby's
fourth world stories which related tales
about these struggles between various
good and evil New Gods Steppenwolf at
one point Justice League says he wants
to take my place among the New Gods well
that's what he meant the evil alien
warlord also mentions his home planet
which very likely means apocalypse the
world occupied by the evil New Gods
after he's failed the part of Russia he
destroyed blooms and flowers in the
style of the good new God's planet New
Genesis Steppenwolf yells for dark side
during his war of conquest that's the
name of the ruler of apocalypse and the
god of evil presumably being set up as a
villain for future Justice League
adventures think DC fans
just between us that's a lot of Justice
League secrets and I'm clearly out of
jokes so thanks for watching
we're dark side
[Applause]
you
[Applause]